[Musica]
pronto lo re stavi dormendo
tra dieci minuti soli dieci minuti si
può anche se c'è tra dieci minuti sono
lì già si sono pronto aspetta certo
arrivo
sì però dai devo mettere il turbo
se poi i comuni mortali mi state
guardando da un telefono che non è la
nord 10
dovete mettere il turbo anche voi e per
farlo se cederà computer
cliccate la valtellina in basso a
sinistra se siete da mobile
cliccate su tre puntini in alto e
mettete velocità di riproduzione 1.5 è
l'unico modo di vedere questo video
e vabbè
[Musica]
bene
no
[Musica]
sì
ecco in questo ragazzo abbiamo finito
potete rimettere a velocità normale sui
vostri dispositivi
e se permettete mila nostro un attimo
perché sono decisamente stanco
questi ragazzi perché questo nuovo
indice sono famiglie volevo salutare
genuflessa che mi sei questo il mio
canale un bacino
ciao cara prego è che devi muoverti
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi avete visto un fa vj
massaia e spero che il video chi sia
piaciuto questo tutorial su come mettere
a posto la casa in velocità comunque
ragazzi io volevo dirvi che nel caso
dovesse mai prendere nella vita un
appuntamento con giulia penna non fatelo
perché no volevo anche dirvi mettete il
turbo al vostro momento della nostra
giornata è fatto di vedere con la tag e
postarlo su instagram io ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto
cosa dire non mi piace anche rifacevano
ideato da letizia non sempre ci dispiace
e non ci riuniamo ho preso malissimo
quindi lui c'è problema di usare i
telecomandi quando chi divide
[Musica]
mammamia alimenti moual basta